chief Palpatine aka Darth Sidious has
always been an enigmatic character in
Star Wars law and much of his role in
the saga remains shrouded in mystery
after his unexpected return at the end
of the Disney sequel trilogy lesson
earth some facts about the evil emperor
you might not know a few years ago one
of the longest-running Star Wars fun
theories was finally confirmed yes Darth
Sidious really did create Anakin
Skywalker all of the clues have been
there for a while of course in the
Phantom Menace Anakin's mother Shmi
tells qui-gon jinn that she became
pregnant with Anakin without the help of
a father while qui-gon discovers that
young Anakin has an abnormally high
medic Thorian counts in Revenge of the
Sith
Palpatine tells Anakin the story of his
former master Darth Plagueis who figured
out how to use midi-chlorians to create
life according to the movies making off
book Lucas actually wrote a scene making
Anakin's parentage explicit but the
lines were cut from the final film years
later in 2018 the 25th issue of Marvel's
Darth Vader comic series settled the
matter by apparently showing Vader
dwelling on the out to a moment that
Palpatine as Darth Sidious
Zapdos mother's womb with Darkseid
energy there's enough wiggle room built
in that Lucasfilm could wreak on this if
they once but for now it's pretty clear
Palpatine is Darth Vader's daddy
not many Star Wars fans are aware of
Emperor Palpatine true connection with
the Jedi Temple thousands of years
before the formation of the Galactic
Republic a Sith erected a shrine on the
planet Khorasan that's emitted Darkseid
energy after defeating the Sith the Jedi
Order built the Jedi Temple directly
over the foundations of the citroen this
was done for two different reasons to
symbolically buried a legacy of the Sith
and to neutralize the dark energy that
the shrine radiated
however after Darth Sidious turfy to the
Jedi Order he converted what was left of
the Jedi Temple into his personal
Imperial Palace and secretly excavated
the sistren Palpatine at the inner thing
of the shrine completed entirely by
Troy's so that even lord Vader would not
be aware of its existence the Emperor
used a refurbished set shrine at his own
personal sanctum where he could meditate
on the dark side of the force
and was eventually planning on allowing
Vader to join him together he believed
they could use a shrines connection to
the darkside to discover more sift
knowledge and powers Palpatine had no
remorse
the people of his own home planet when
he planned operation cinder a
contingency plan to ensure the longevity
of the Galactic Empire should he ever be
killed Palpatine believed that if the
Empire was unable to prevent his
assassination and the entire
organization was a failure and did not
deserve to live on without him in order
to fulfill his vision
Palpatine created a plan to annihilate
both the Empire and his enemies should
he ever perish and entrusted a select
group of imperial officers with a duty
of rebuilding a new Empire a plan was to
use a series of satellites to form a
climate disruption array capable of
laying waste to resistance our like
planets with catastrophic weather events
after the Emperor's apparent death had
drawn the Battle of Endor one of these
climate disruption arrays was used to
wreak havoc upon Palpatine's home planet
of Naboo satellites created massive
hurricanes and electrical storms have
ravaged the surface of the planet it was
only through the actions of Leia Organa
and Lando Calrissian that the rebels
were able to destroy the climate
disruption erase and stop the people of
Naboo from being completely wiped out
Darth Sidious was a master set user and
skilled fighter but he didn't take over
the Republic by force he used trickery
and deceit as such his Holly surprising
that Palpatine used his gear for
psychological manipulation well before
he was on the way to becoming Emperor
nor that he was one of the Galactic
centers most skilled propagandists
Palpatine's predecessor supreme
chancellor valorum was a weak willed and
indecisive leader who often cowards held
to special interests ensure he wasn't up
to the job so when valorum needed to
sway the hearts and minds of the people
he often uploaded his duties to
everyone's favorite Sith Lord in hiding
the book star wars propaganda a
collection of in-universe propaganda
pieces has some of Palpatine's work
including a striking invitation to the
Republic's 1,000 year anniversary
celebration Palpatine didn't stop
meddling in the Republic's propaganda
machine after he took power either when
the Republic commissioned posters to
bolster support for the Clone Wars
Palpatine explicitly forbade artists
from producing materials featuring the
Jedi publicly Palpatine said that he
didn't want to make the Jedi who were
already worried about being military
leaders more uncomfortable
privately Palpatine didn't want people
siding with the Jedi since he planned to
scapegoat them as part of his coup once
the war ended death wasn't the end for
Palpatine even after he died in the
second Death Star
plans lived on years before Palpatine
crowned himself Emperor he established
an underground observatory and the
planet jakku Rey's homeworld in the
force awakens his plan stuff it full of
sift relics with the power to cause an
explosion and that in the event of his
death detonate the whole thing and wipe
out the Empire and the Rebel Alliance in
one fell swoop
Palpatine figured any empire that was
inept enough to let him die didn't
deserve to survive and winnowing out the
Empire's weaker elements would give it
the freedom to reform into something
stronger if his enemies died in the
explosion - so much the better
purple team but a man named galius racks
in charge of the plan which unfolds and
chuck wendig's aftermath trilogy of
books it almost works
Rex manages to lure the Empire and the
New Republic to jakku for a final
showdown but a team of good and bad guys
stop the planet from blowing up still
after the battle the Empire heads off to
the Unknown Regions to regroup where it
transforms into the leaner mean first
order in the long term mission
accomplished
Palpatine looked down on luxury
preferring a Spartan lifestyle that fit
with his brutal set philosophy
discomfort isn't great for impressing
politicians however so Palpatine also
maintained his own pleasure craft which
he called the imperialists he must have
loved the ship a lot so every single one
of Palpatine secret observations which
were home to desist Lords most treasured
artifacts contained a full replica of
the craft the Imperialis was fast enough
to outmaneuver a Star Destroyer had all
kinds of fancy weapons and defensive
tools and was stuffed full of treasure
making it a perfect target for smugglers
and pirates those who are dumb enough to
take on the Emperor himself anyway
well that description fits Lando
Calrissian perfectly in Marvel's Lando
comic miniseries mr. Carissa and booty
Imperialis and ends up on Palpatine's
bad side while Palpatine sends Star
Destroyers and bounty hunters after
Lando none of them can bring the
Imperialis home so Palpatine orders a
ship destroyed
Lando escapes but the Imperialis has
lost forever a dark robe saggy pale skin
and yellow eyes should have given it
away
but even after Palpatine transformed the
Republic into the Empire he worked very
hard to hide his Seth background people
knew or the very least rumors suggested
that Darth Vader was familiar with the
ways of the force that Palpatine was his
master was a tightly guarded secret a
core
the books laws of the Sith and Tarkin
only a few people were privy to what
publi team was his apprentices Darth
Maul Count Dooku and Darth Vader they
all knew of course so that His Royal
Guards almost everyone else was kept in
the dark even Grand Moff Tarkin one of
Palpatine's closest allies and most
trusted confidence only suspected that
Palpatine was a Seth he didn't know for
sure it's not clear why Palpatine did
influence a Sith heritage although it's
easy to guess but one if Palpatine spent
his entire career operating in the
shadows
why start moving into the light now for
another - Palpatine information was
power there's no use in telling people
more than they need to know every fact
that's revealed can eventually be used
against you lots of Palpatine's
backstory comes from James Lucy knows
dark Plagueis which is there longer
considered canonical in Disney's new
streamlined Star Wars universe still of
Plagueis as legacy lives on in a few
ways you ever hear the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise take a sister's eye
it's a conquer death plays a major role
in Anakin's turn to the dark side and
could be a key factor in Palpatine's
mysterious unexplained return in the
rise of Skywalker
finally while Palpatine killed a
Plagueis while his master slept he did
take a souvenir with him 1 140 Pegasus
trusty protocol droid Palpatine didn't
establish the Empire to get famous
he just wanted power while serving as a
senator made Palpatine a celebrity he
retreated from the public eye once he
became emperor letting the Imperial
ruling council handle most of the
day-to-day work of governing and leaving
nasiha tasks up to his apprentice Darth
Vader as a result of Palpatine was safe
from his enemies and could devote as
much time as he wanted to his own
pursuits but at an unintended side
effect because no one saw him some
conspiracy theorists argued that
Palpatine was dead
the most common story alleged that the
Jedi killed Palpatine during their
uprising and that the Imperial leaders
were using Palpatine's name to grab
power for themselves the Empire tried to
dispel these rumors in a few ways in
Tarkin Tarkan's friends Niles Tennant
submits that the ruling council sends
out fake flying motorcades to make it
look like Palpatine was traveling from
place to place in aftermath we learned
that the Empire used body Devils to give
the impression that Palpatine was giving
speeches or making other public
appearances in reality however Palpatine
preferred to stay at home
although he was very much alive like
Darth Plagueis before him Palpatine was
obsessed with unlocking the secrets of
immortality which clearly came into play
during the rise of Skywalker however not
all of his experiments paid off just
look at what happened to project
Blackwing instead of discovering the key
to everlasting life the Empire
accidentally created stormtroopers
zombies in the mobile game Star Wars
commander which is canon because then
the Disney everything is purple team
recruits a bunch of scientists make
Imperial soldiers live forever instead
they create a virus that turns the
corpses into members of the Living Dead
the virus ultimately creates an entire
army of so-called death troopers but the
combined forces of the Empire and the
Rebel Alliance contain the outbreak
saving the galaxy from a zombie
apocalypse still the death troopers
legacy lives on in one key way allegedly
the death troopers sedum Rock one who
has special ops soldiers not zombies got
their name from Palpatine's failed
experiments hey it's a good name may as
well use it twice don't let anyone tell
you that Papa teen didn't have a sense
of humor the way he treated the Senate
proves that he does despite what you
might think Palpatine didn't dissolve
the Galactic Senate as soon as he took
power in fact he kept it around for
decades before the Death Star Palpatine
saw the Senate is a valuable political
tool that lets its constituents feel
that they had some say in politics as a
means of quashing potential rebellions
even though he had all the power that's
why he said I am the Senate it was an
illusion of course over time power moved
from the Senate to local regional
leaders robbing the politicians of any
real influence once Palpatine created
the Death Star which would let him
control the galaxy via fear instead of
politics he disbanded the Senate
entirely but that didn't happen until
the beginning of a new hope the whole
time and nobody bothered to let the
Senators know what was happening wait a
minute
how did this happen we're smarter than
this in a comic and a ninth issue of
Star Wars rebels magazine the crew of
the ghost runs into a senator from the
planet farad who still believes in the
legislative body the Senate says still
debate policy she says they still pass
bills which they sent to Palpatine to be
signed into law they don't realize that
Palpatine simply ignores them they think
they're making a difference instead
they're frittering away in the Senate
chamber doing absolutely nothing part
breaking kind of tried to file arias no
absolutely check out one of our newest
videos right here
us even more looper videos buy your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
do it
[Music]